So I joined the Oklahoma
State Police Department in 1974.
When I retired in 2008, I was
at home watching The Young
and the Restless on the TV when
my wife came through there,
and she said, you will
find something to do.
Back in the 1800s, you
got caught the cattle,
what happened?
They'd find a rope
and they'd find a tree
and they'd stamp your
ticket right there.
Hey, what you got, man?
The rancher called me.
He had yesterday
morning about 10
steers that were in his corral.
And when he got here yesterday
afternoon, they were gone.
Cattle [inaudible] really
lucrative for the people
who steal these cattle.
If I steal your TV that
you spent $2000 for,
I maybe get $50 for it.
But the cattle aren't like that.
If I steal your cow, I can
take that cow to a stock market
and it's going to bring
$1,200, $1,500 a head.
It's quick money, if
you don't get caught.
These tracks right here
looks they've got out.
We want to stop this
kind of thing happening.
But what these
guys, when we arrest
these people when
they're stealing cattle,
it is not uncommon anymore.
We hear it every day.
The reason why is because
of their addictions to meth.